with melo you were training with him
a lot a lot of videos were like coming
up on my timeline when he was not on a
roster when everyone was counting him
out
for sure and that was obviously a huge
mistake
yeah it was um man i won the breakfast
club one time
and i said i think mellow this is when
he wasn't in the nba
i said i think that mello is better than
60 percent of the nba right now
the media like destroyed me i thought i
was gonna get cancelled
and four months later this guy's
starting in the nba
which means if you're an nba starter
you're better
so it's funny how the media works um
mellow's back year 18. he's playing
great this year yeah man i think like
that just shows you like with melo like
you know this guy's one of the most
prolific scores in
nba history for sure top ten
yeah and it's and like he never had any
like crazy injuries or anything i think
people just like just thought like
the league had moved past what he does
and it's like that's not he just
ended up in shitty situations with
oklahoma city and houston like
mike d'antoni did not [ __ ] with him you
know what i mean like
so i'm glad he got that second chance
yeah what do you think is the biggest
misconception about someone like
carmilla anthony um
i personally hate it when someone's like
all right because he didn't win a ring
then i'm gonna you know not give him the
credit for
you know some people are on that and i
understand to for your legacy but
at the end of the day yummy people play
in the nba i think he's ninth all-time
scorer for all time like he's done some
amazing things he hasn't won a ring
hopefully he will win a ring
but you shouldn't be judged just off a
ring yeah i think like you said
how many like when you really break down
how many people have rings compared to
the people have played in the league
it's
it's insane i even think during our era
like
the last 20 years it's been harder than
ever to get a ring
these but these super teams right i mean
look even if you go back to like
when the celtics got ray allen and kevin
garnett that was to me the first
that was like the first super team of
this era yeah
where it was like oh and free agency
they just got they just went and got a
big three and then they won the ring
year one yeah that was the beginning of
it and then the
spurs had a dynasty which you know and
then of course there was
the lakers and yeah you know and then
and then the heat
yeah and and then the cavs and then the
warriors yeah